so I think our last speaker of this
session is
going to speak about Quantum and minimum
Circle size program
thank you for having me here and thank
you for coming to our talk and my name
is knifeway and this is based on John
Wall with Jimmy and Raider and Jerry
so yeah I just briefly uh review the
minimum circuit size problem to make
sure that we are on the same page so for
the name answer key size problem uh we
the input is a truth table of some
function f and and sound integer S I
want to decide whether there exists a
circuit of size at most as that computes
that and here are some interesting facts
about the million circuits as problem
first the input size is actually Q to
the N so in efficient equation for mcsp
runs these two runs in time positive to
the end so which means a two to the
bigger and and we know that when when
the size is too small or too large the
problem is easy because if it is too
small we can do both for search and we
can solve it in no problem time and when
the size is very large then every
functions have circulated with their
size
okay and the capacity of mcsp is quite
mysterious it is an MP intermediate
problem right now so the problem is
definitely in mp because you can just
view the Builder circuit as a witness
and the verify just check all the two to
the input to see whether the witness is
consistent with the uh the Boolean
function
and mtsps are known to bring any
subclass of NP and we know that SDK
reduce to mcsp value randomized
reduction and there is a conjunctional
set that rule Force searches the optimal
or say is the best algorithm for the
mcsp
and you know stopping since mcsp
efficiently implies breaking one-way
function so that's why some people
believe that if we do have the if we
believe that no cryptography exists the
mcsp should not be in p
and then there are many results showing
that the variance of mcsp is actually MP
Hardware MP complete
so here are some of the results this is
another excited list and so for example
the dmvsp is MP heart or dnf xor mcsp is
empty heart and then all conversion of
the mcsp is also MP heart and multi
output partium CSP that's the formula
mcspr or MP heart
and I think the difference between mtsp
Star and partial CSP is that this one
you are just giving the non-zero and
other defined the entry with the barrier
to the S input and this one you give the
four pulling table as the input
okay and one interesting about mcsp is
that it connects many problems in still
way of computer science
for example for circuit if you can show
the mcsp is easy then you can show like
lots of circular but for example circuit
lower Bound for p to the MP and also
ESPN equal to zpp or you can show mcsps
in bqp you can have new circuit lower
Bound for pqe which is a Quantum version
of E
and then you can also have like learning
algorithms if mcsp is easy then you can
have a pack learning algorithm for like
any function which has has polynomial
size circuit
and also you can you can show something
about cryptography as I mentioned if
mcsp is easy then you can break all
one-way functions and prg and also SDK
reduce to mcsp or suppose that we have
the indistinguishable obfuscater then
set reduced to mcsp so which means
there's that then mcsp are equivalent
under randomized reduction
and also you can have average case
complexity if you can show that mcsp is
MP hard then you can show equivalence of
worst case and the average case harness
of MP
so this is now the exhaustive list of
all the results corresponding to mcsp
because there are so many nice results
that I cannot put in just one slide but
you can see the mcsb connects many
problems in PCs
so the reason that we try to study the
quantum CSE is because that we attend
the mcfd washer into stock 2020 and we
are really inspired by the you know by
mcsp like the harness is so mysterious
and connects many problems in PCs
and we also noticed that mcsp is asking
the complexity of classical circuit
complexity for classical objects in
other words it is Boolean functions and
you know in Quantum Computing it is very
natural to consider equivalent circuit
complexity and we are also very
interesting to know you know Quentin
study compensity for uh cleaner objects
like for example we have Quentin States
we have hamiltonian we have unitaries
and many Quantum algorithms are trying
to understand some properties about like
stage hamiltonians or unitary
so in this work uh in addition to
consider classical object like Boolean
function we also want to consider
circuit equivalent circuit complexity of
you know coordinate States or unitaries
so the goal is that we try to study a
compressor of a problem and asking for
the financial capacity of Queen objects
and we also want to connect Quantum
problems through the quantum CSP and as
genius said in the paper we try to
understand Quantum Computing through a
lens of meta complexity
so uh briefly we Define these three
problems so the first problem is similar
to the classical mcsp but instead of
considering the classical circuit
capacity we consider the quantum circuit
complexity and for the unitariance
diversion we change your targets so here
the input is for unitary when the input
is some Matrix and then for this Matrix
we want to consider which the optimal
equivalent circuit they can output the
same Matrix or we consider the input as
a vector of that represented and qubit
state or we just have many copies of the
quinine States and we want to cons we
want to know the circuit capacity of
output in the state
so these are all the three versions of
mcsp we consider in this work
we have two versions the first one I
have the full description of the state
so it will be a two to the N dimensional
you know vector and the second version
is that you can have many copies of s
yeah
and we actually we don't know the
relationship between them uh I think it
is easier to see that it is easy to see
that uh if you if you can solve this one
and when you consider your teeth to be
large enough you can do a state
tomography to have a reduction but other
than that I don't know any relationship
between these two versions but as I said
like the second version have more
applications in the quantum Computing
yeah we will talk about that later
yes
that's what they say in the second
version that's actually an individuals
so you will give a large Vector so like
a castle better
positions yeah all localization with
certain uh actors yes
and because we're talking about the
present circuit complexity I want to
give you a very brief introduction about
Fitness
gaze and output
so the usually we can describe the
exponent circuit in this form so you
have constantly as input usually you
have two parts the first part is input
like uh your problem and you have some
working qubits here to help you to do
calculation and you apply some Quantum
Gates on it and then you have going to
stay here and then you want to do some
you know measurement to transfer the
content information back to the
classical information
so mathematically any nqb state which we
can describe in this form so which is
dimension of CJ and the KJ so kjoy you
can consider it as a you know as a 22dm
vector and address element is one and
all the other elements are 0. another
thing about the CJ here is that CJ is a
complex number and and the sum of square
needs to be equal to one
and usually for equivalent circuit we
have like input denoted as k x so which
means that the X element is one and then
we have lots of Ancilla Cubase there are
all zero and you can have polynomial
menu and see that Cubase
so this space will represent the two to
the poly n dimensional vector
okay and how about the Quentin Gates so
for Quantum Gates uh they are unitary so
it is a matrix and you need to set it
you need to have this property which is
U there U equal to U there you you take
it equal to you take a u equal to
Identity and you think is the conjugate
and transpose and for example this gate
we call it C naught uh this is in this
Matrix and for the hadama gate here
which is this one one one minus one and
you can easily verify that they are
identical they are unitary decided by
this property
anybody when we consider you know Quinn
and circuit when you consider all the
gates are from the universal cases so
which means that if I have located then
I can approximate to any unitaries
um you know we have
so uh and in this talk we just consider
that we have a thinner than all single
cubic unitary but for some of our
results we need to consider
specifications but for simulation you
just consider that you can have any
single unitaries and the C naught and
this is the universal case that you can
use this case to approximate to all unit
carries
and in the last I just talked a little
bit about measurement so the measurement
just consider that you have some
questions stay here and you measure it
in the something we call a standard
basis State then you can get the index
trade with probability corresponding to
the coefficient like the CJ square and
the most famous example is shown in this
cat which means that the cat is in this
day like uh dead and alive and you
measure it you get that with probability
one Health and the life was probably one
Health
okay
so uh that's about the permanent circuit
as I said you have input State Quantum
Gates when in circuits you have
equivalent State here as output and then
you measure it you get your output with
certain probability
so there are several things that is very
important about current circuit when we
want to study mcsp first you can see
that Quantum Computing is generally
render and no have Arrow so which means
that probably we cannot directation
problem it is more natural to consider
promise problem which means that our
algorithm can give you like some answer
with high probability but not always
correct
is reversible because it is unitary so
you can have you then you can have you
taker so which help us to come up with
search the decision induction and also
self-reduction for the unitary version
and the slave version
another thing is that we have like
Ancilla cubits and this encyclopeds
actually make the problem harder so we
cannot put like all these mcsd problem
into MP instead we can only put that
into qcma which is a Quantum version of
marine answer
okay and there are various universal
opening cases as I mentioned and some of
our results only hold for particular
Gazette
and another another like a trivial
observation is that if you have a small
classical circuit for some function
which means that you also have a small
Quantum circuit for the same function
okay and any question so far
so I will talk about the mqcsp first
which is that I want to consider the
financial capacity of Boolean function I
would consider the harness of it and I
won't consider its connection to crypto
learning and the Queen and circular
so here's the definition about the
Boolean circuit size problem I just call
it m2csp
so the problem is actually in qcma and
uh right now it is in mp it is because
of the enzyme Cubase and I will tell you
that later and we also show that uh
multi-op and qcsp is MP heart which is
which generalized the result by elango
love and the Olivera in 2020 we found
that uh we can follow their proof and
but with some additional Technique we
can show that result also holds for the
mqcsp
and we can also show the mqcsp SDK SDK
heart and because mqcsb Oracle can be
used to break prg which is kind of like
the period Paradigm if you have a mqcsp
or local then you can have the quantum
natural property there against Clinton
circuit yes
uh it is hard because the we we try that
one interesting to see and very hard
towards a complete problem
you are given a circuit that represents
that uh that building table uh sorry
let's choose paper then I can show that
that problem is
so it's kind of like if you're a large
circuit I want to compress it to ask you
where there is a smaller circuit for the
for the large circuit and it's not done
uh multi-output or single output I can
show that there are qcmware but I don't
know whether I can put it inside qcl but
that problem is even harder than qcma I
think yeah but for the truth table why I
don't know how to show it as excuse me
very hard yeah sure just something
you're talking more about this on steel
while sealants are uh no so so the
question is whether we can show and qcsp
excuse yeah
okay
so yes the reason why is SDK hard is
that it's a natural property yeah
yeah so that's all the other in addition
to being sck it's hard it has all the
other advantages of natural property
um I think for that result you don't you
just you just use the natural party then
you can show right so I mean so you also
get like the randomization and so on
yeah
yes
so here I will show you like quite
enthusiastic uh you know it's qcla but
we start from trying to put it inside
the MP first okay
so suppose after the quaintance strategy
with size at most T then we just there
CP the opponent circuit that computes F
without using any NCR cubics like here
and then the certificate will say the
witness is the statistic
and then you know and we cannot run C
because V is a classical algorithm in NP
since but on the other hand suppose
since we allow B to run into to the
bigger and time right because the input
size is 2 to the n
so actually we can try to just compute
the unitary that corresponding to the
Circuit C okay and then given the
unitary you can try to see whether the
unitary is consistent with the no the
truth table so in this way you can put
in qcsp inside mp uh no you know if your
staircase is only not work only work on
the NQ bits okay
so it looks like this is kind of like a
you know this just a follow the
classical proof of like mcsp using MP
um but why if we allow like poly and see
like Cubase for our circuit
so now you have polyanka bits
you know you know like the corresponding
urinary will be a two totally poly and
uh unitary
so the dimension would be 2 to the N
times 2 to the protein 2 to the power
the n and you know the verify even
cannot be able to write to write down
all the unit types in you know two to
the bigger and time so this approach
does not work directly because uh we
verify doesn't have sufficient time to
you know to compute the unitary about C
so the problem will be the problem is
just the Boolean type of F and the
corresponding integer s and you can use
arbitrary many you know the
NCR qubits but it needs to be polynomial
in end to compute your function
yeah it needs to be smaller than S
correct okay
or yeah I just risk um yes more than as
it's called
I think it also depends on how many
things you you can allow if you're alone
like morphine it can depends on some
constant times as something like that
yeah
oh but you know like we can put it
inside to CMA the reason is that if I
come up with the circuit then I can just
you know the quantum verify can just
improve in the circuit and then we can
compute everything right so in this way
we can put it inside the qcf by
complexity class
so good so we can see this one and then
I won't talk a little bit about nqcsp
and its connection to other you know
other problems
so for example if we have uh if we have
connected no one-way function the mqcsp
is not in the pqp and this follows that
uh you can use the mqcsp to break all
prg and then uh to prepare behalf G and
then you can use it to break the one-way
function
but we can also show that if you have a
post content you know uh
indistinguishable obfuscater then MP is
not in core rqp implies mqcsv is not in
b2p so clock QP is the Quantum polymer
time with perfect soundness and the
boundary Arrow components
however the other direction is unknown
because mqcsp is unknown to be in mp so
we can approve the other direction but
in the classical proof actually you can
prove the equivalence and such that you
can say that is equivalent to encloses
and CSP under randomized reduction and
another thing is that you you may try to
replace the MP here but if you want to
replace the MP here to be you know qcma
uh it's a little bit mysterious because
I don't know which company problem we
can try to start by using the nqcsp or
local but like those are like
interesting questions we can study
yeah so in other words like here what we
want to know is that uh suppose we we
know the harness of enthusi SP like
whether it is easy or hard can we use it
to help us to build crypto graphic
Primitives or we can say like
cryptocurrency implies the hardness of
mqcsp
yes so actually like we are trying to
say whether we can use the enthusiastic
key to come up with something with color
so don't rendered states which means
that you have a future personal State
play is indistinguishable from the
random tendency
and we can and actually there are
several assumptions that this PRT might
be uh how to say a weaker assumption
than the you know putting secure one-way
function yeah so that's an interesting
interesting thing yeah because the
difference between the first and the
second is
um
okay
so the first results show that uh you
know like everything is increases break
one-way function and this is how you
need the quantum IO to show that you
have to show the swim swing you know I'm
not sure but there's a
the first Quantum IO implied post
Quantum one way
has absorber they separate that as well
I think so yeah
so it kind of depends so the io is not
monotone in complexity yeah because
let's assume assume that that
is be different from the B but then
that's that's kind of contradicting what
the the whole assumption here because
they're just saying you do have a
Quantum algorithm for all of NP
or or if you know we're just trying to
argue that we don't have a Quantum
algorithm for all of mqsb oh sorry
yeah so if you if you assumed that P did
not equal NP then the conclusion it's
not exactly trivial but it's the sort of
the mqcsp is not an eqp is sort of
similar in flavor to the p is not an MP
so like if we're assuming that already
then we don't necessarily like it
doesn't necessarily make sense to argue
for it so yeah yeah that makes sense
yeah
so
yeah and okay we have also like General
lifestyle we start in uh KK 16 like to
about like Quentin pack learning
so actually what we can show is that if
you have an efficient classical pack
learning algorithm for bqps dash poly
then it is equivalent to sell their
existing efficient randomized algorithm
for mqcsp or you can consider the
quantum learning algorithm if you have
efficient learning algorithm for
peculine uh no circuit Class C so here
the circuit class can be uh you know
Quantum circuit class or classical
circuit class then there is an efficient
clinical equation for the cmqcsp
the second race are actually many
follows the uh the technique in in the
urban National adult in 2019 presented
by Alex yesterday
so the main idea is that if I have mqcsp
over calling I can have no I can have a
Content natural property against
quinance the key complexity quinancial
key class
so start from there then you can
generalize the classical result to the
printing City
so in this way we can relax when
learning theory into the harness of
mqcsp
so you can also have the connection
between m2csp and the circuit lower
Bound for example if mqcsp is easy then
you can show circular Bound for eqe and
the pqb to the qcma and the idea still
follow the uh is still follow that uh
you know kind of natural property
against permanent circuit passes and we
also need some diagonization Lema for
the opponent circuits and we also have a
harnessed amplification harness
magnification and the fine growing
complexity
so like grocery store you need to
somehow prove some Quantum versions of
something about the prg like the I think
the amplification one we need to prove
that the Clinton security of the implant
Gasol and the weakest in prg
uh generation and then we also need a
Quentin security generator and for the
mechanic magnification restart we need
the printer and titrator labor for the
function
yeah but like lots of results usually
you can you can follow the classical
results and try to fix the issues there
when you consider Quantum circuits
okay and then I want to spend a little
bit more time on the quantum objects so
for Queen objects uh here we consider
unitary opponent States
so here when we said that we have a
circuit that computes U which means that
for all the states you if you consider
in a product the inner product is close
to one
or can we say about we can compute the
state s by using C which means that
start from zero C account zero the inner
product between AC and C are close to
one okay
and then we will still first sure that
these two problems are into CMA we can
and we can also show some reductions
about these two properties like the
these two problems have searched to
decision reductions and also the smcsp1
has something we call the self reduction
and we can I will also previously say
some application about these two
problems in Quantum computing
okay so first of all smcsp is in qcma
so still we start from the witness the
witness is just a circuit of the size uh
you know at the most T that computes as
and we also have a verification so for
the verification uh we use something we
call the swap test so for the swap test
which is this circuit uh you have two
states five and the side input to a
circuit and the probability that first
cubic output 0 will be one Health Plus
the inner product of the two states
right
so if the two states um no equivalent
which uh the inner product will be one
so the probability that you were output
0 is one and if the two states are
orthogonal or very different then the
probability that your output 0 will be
one Health around one Health one so
using a swap test you can check whether
the two states are you know closed or
they are orthogonal or they are far
so for the MC for the SM CSP what we do
is that okay after the verified gallon
circuit you just prepare the state I
just prepare the state C of zero and you
also need to prepare the state s of the
input so the first thing is that if you
have a vector of n cube is there which
is a 2 to the N or vectors then given a
classical description you can prepare
the state using two to the N control
rotations so just you need the bigger to
the end time then you can prepare step
for B and the second versions that you
got arbitrary many copies of s right so
in this case because you already have
the S you don't need to prepare the
state by yourself and then you just run
this to you just uh you know fill these
two states into a swap test and then you
do this test many enough times then you
can distinguish whether they are close
or they are far far from each other
what does it mean for this problem
and the input 2 case where your input is
not even like
yeah so that's a good question so for
the first input you can say it is uh
promise qcma well second one right now
you only have you have the question the
opponent stage at the input so it is not
the it is not uh you know a Christian
made problem so you can just say that it
has a qci proof or you can Define some
capacity cards which is called stay qcma
or something such that the input problem
is when it's based and trying to decide
something yeah so actually in our paper
we don't say it is in qcma we just said
that we have a qcms protocol to certify
themselves yeah
oh and then uh the second thing is
try to prove that uncsp is in qcna so a
naive approach is that you still run a
swap test for all computational faces
that say I have CNU and then you just
try to check whether they are equal from
0 to 2 to the N minus one well this uh
does not work because uh let me differ
on super pollution State like it is
possible let's see what's input 0 plus 1
give you D1 minus one but U is still 0
plus 1 give you 0 Plus 1. you know in
this case you can you have no way to
distinguish them and also we have to
consider like you know uh NCR cube is so
there may be some entanglement between
your output qubits and uh you know
concealer qubits and that will introduce
another phase to the you know to your
output so this approach does not work so
we need to introduce a new a new test we
call the coherent test
so you just do swap test on all states
of the phone uh one one one was square
root 2 of a plus b and here ABR
arbitrary competition basis States
that suppose the circuit passed the
standard basic test here and also the
coherent test then you can show that
actually they are greater than OAB and
also like the this price the Ancilla
qubits the state on the NCR qubits are
almost the same okay and after using
that after we have these two uh two
tests and then have this limit we can
show that actually uh if you can pass
these two tests then uh you know the two
the unit tests and the circuits are the
step or they are close
okay
and then we can say something about the
search to the station reduction so we
know that for uh it is unknown whether
mcsp has searched to decision reduction
right so if and uh and actually there
are some research showing that okay if
uh mcsp is
um social decision reductions about some
variance of mcsp like let's get version
mcsp average mcsp or mfsp so which is a
Formula version and also this one
showing that uh if the work has mcsp is
in BPP then you have a randomized volume
a person for finding and of course the
optimal circuit
and also there's some relation barrier
for determining research to decision
reductions for ncsp
so the main idea here is that because
unitary is reversible so we can try to
uncompute the get from you so here is a
reduction so the goal is that you are
giving you and then Oracle for
umcsp and you try to find the opponent
circuit C such that use the UMC spro
code to help you to find us uh to uh
sorry
um you know to find a circuit so here we
first use the umcs vehicle to 5S equal
to no Quantum circuit complexity of U
and then we start from I equal to one
and then we just do some while loop so
what the while loop do is actually that
uh when you have so for in the first
layer you have U and you just get some
uh G1 and then you compute uh from G1 uh
taker
and then you use the mcsp or local try
to check whether the circuit capacity
decrease or not if it decreases means
that okay the guess I met is correct so
I can say the first get is G1 and then I
can set this one to be a new U and then
I try to I try to come up with the
second G2 okay and then you uncompute
YouTube one bigger and then if the
circuit complexity decrease I know that
my guess is correct then I can put G2 as
a second gate and I can do this
iteratively in a less I can get U1 G2 to
GS which is the circuit we want
okay and you know in this way you can
have um now you can have a search to
decision reductions for you and CSP yes
this isn't something special
yes
were you using reversibility is that the
number of of inputs is implicitly
growing so it's a matter of input
doesn't work so you could introduce a
new gate
um
oh I see but then it would be only on
partial inputs yeah because you wouldn't
have all the possible
it would be a a promise problem yeah
that works partium CSP
so for this reaction uh also worked for
the sncsp department so this one is a
unitary but you can do a stimulus theme
for the sncsp
but on this I want to give a note about
this reduction so the reduction uh right
now on the code if we don't consider it
and see that to this so in particular so
suppose of the input is 2tm by 2D and
Matrix then our circuits also is also
for encubus without any and zero qubits
so the main reason is that if I consider
you and then I can compute it back from
a larger unitary then in addition to
case the you know the gate which you
want I also need to guess like which
part of I also need to guess the unitary
and Sila qubits right
so the main reason you know like because
I don't have the full full description
about a unitary or state so I need to
make some case about it and then so two
best of our knowledge if you don't have
too many Ancilla Cubase then you can
just use the Epson net then you can
probably you can still you know you can
still do a search to decision reductions
but if you have too many and select two
bits then uh this reduction doesn't work
because it is inefficient so
the unitary version of
for for the unitary version and the
state version
does it make sense
like when you have the unitary version
yeah do you consider that your
the state uh sorry the circuit that
implements it could also act on more
acidoscope or a select cubics I think it
is possible right or you need to prove
that
um you know like additional NCR group it
doesn't help you to compute the urinary
efficiently
yeah
okay and answer your question um yeah
yeah so at least for the stay version it
is quite clear that if you have more
energy activity you can have it to
prepare some states efficiently
yeah
but uh the thing is that
um you know like we don't know how many
mgrs you can use for your no to prepare
uh some unicaries towards States more
efficient rooms
so that's uh now that's a that's it uh
important thing about this search with
your introductions so too many
Scientifics are reduction fail and if
there's a number of things that's more
then I think you can use Epson there to
complete the truth
okay and I just spent a little bit more
time on the self-reduction for the smcsp
so how we call this smssp the
self-reduction is that if you can
compute the circuit complexity of n
minus one qubit state then you can use
this Evolution to approximate opponent
circuit capacity of n qubit state so
like this formula so this is the circuit
capacity of PSI with the approximation
ratio Epsilon and then this one can be
upper boundary or lower bounded by the
circuit capacity of M minus one cubits
they said level and the side one
and here I said when it's that one is
defined as here so say so for any no
inquiry State we can use the Schmid
decomposition to decomposite into zero
set zero plus one side one so this is a
standard way to you know to decompose
the state into two uh two systems
and then uh what this reduction do is
that what is it uh now this bank is hold
is that okay we can just consider that
we uh we can estimate everywhere and one
by you know by have sufficiently many uh
copies of sine and then we just consider
two cases the first cases is that either
a0 or A1 which is very small
so which means that PSI is close to the
other for example if we say that it was
very small which means that size close
to zero and the size zero because uh
this branch is almost the uh you know
negligible
and then in this case uh the circuit
capacity of PSI can be bounded by a
circuit capacity of uh size zero right
so you can have the bond by just using 0
and the size zero and the second case
there will be non-trivial so the second
case is that
um you know both both edible and the A1
they have separation totally large
coefficient
so the lower part is that okay if I give
you a sign and then you just measure it
like no many enough times then you can
come up with side with this side I was
high probability right so in this way
you can just you know have many enough
like here I just said that oh this
should be big Omega Epsilon so just you
know measure it many enough times then
you can have the uh you can have set
and how about the upper bound so for the
upper bound you we need to use the
following circuit so this circuit is
that okay if I have C1 and the C 0 they
compute set 0 and the second one and
then I can use this control rotation to
help me to you know to construct PSI and
then you know if you want to have a
control rotation of specifics okay you
need to have some constant blow up so
that's why we have an additional
constant roll up layer here okay
so in this way you can have an upper
body lower Bound for the circuit
capacity of five if you know how to
compute a circuit complexity of Cellular
in the same one
okay
and in the last we would I talked about
the application so one thing is that
actually we have another reduction that
can reduce the Gap version of mqcsp to
uncsp
and based on this reduction we can
generalize many applications of mqcsp to
um CSP like you can also use umcsp to
invert one-way function to harness
magnification when circuit lower bounds
and so on
and for the smcsp if you just consider a
state version which is that you are
given many states instead of a full
description about the opponent States
then you can use it to break Financial
random States or you can use it to
estimate one whole volume under the ads
safety correspondence is equal to B
conjecture and you know the dictionary
map is computed or something you know
something which uh people assumed in the
equivalent gravity
uh you can use this one to estimate the
complexity of certain questions and the
comparison of backwardness they actually
corresponding to the no Wormhole volume
in the ads
so we can also use this one to sustain
some problem because the same state
tomography problem and by that one you
also need to use the search to decision
search to decision reduction yes
okay
so that's all the results we have in the
work and I just want to give a quick
conclusion understand open questions
so the quick conclusion is that okay we
started harnessing applications of
quantum CSP we started Boolean unitary
States and we also come we only consider
Quantum circuit complexity of that
and here are some open questions that we
can consider like right now we only say
that those problems are in qcma but we
don't know whether they are MP hard or
qcma heart so it is interesting to know
whether it is possible to police
problems inside MP or can you prove MP
harness of these problems or say can you
prove is qsdk hard or other subclass
hard
and also like the harness of Queen MCS
we want to know whether it connects to
some uh you know Quantum cryptographic
Primitives that uh just used recently
like content slow running States EFI or
one-way State function and so on so
forth or connected to the you know
Quantum commitment and
and we also want to know whether there
are reductions between Quinter and csps
so like we only know mqcsp reduced to
the unitary version but we don't know
other reductions between different
versions so we won't really want to know
about the relationship between different
version of mcsp
and we also want to consider what
schedule adjectives on your content
reductions for mcsp or consider harness
education and CSP and also the fine
grain complexity and the pronounce SP
like for example if I assume ncsp
um is hard for a specific long time then
can ensure that other problems are hard
above some lower bound
and also other Quantum meta complexity
like Quantum version of Commonwealth
complex
yeah and that's all thank you
[Applause]
so do you uh have a feeling of whether
it should uh
qma art or uh do you think it should be
I think
so as I said I don't think it will be
qcm so because as I said so I can only
put back a harder version excuse in
their heart and I don't know whether it
will be
yeah so I just said it is hard to say
right but right now I I still think even
it is it is still very hard to prove
that it is probably the first day it's
trying to see whether it is empty now
and then
another thing is that we don't have many
qcma complete programs there so that's
another reason that it is hard to
imagine what kind of problems can be is
they reduce too much no to qmc sap yeah
so it translates to the quantum setting
or uh five million ncsp star but
um
I remember that there are some issues
there but that vocabulous we try they
will try that multi up when CSV and CSP
is the two versions I remember the uh
your mcsp Styles so we haven't been able
to successfully down there but I cannot
record the reason right now okay
because
sometimes you can use a very small
circuit to come through the high
complexity
okay the quick question is that we
haven't considered that kind of stay
version but we can try yeah
questions
thank you
so I think the other company